قال الرئيس الاوكراني ان النتيجه التي
توصلت اليها الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه بشان وجود القنبله القذره المزعومه
في اوكرانيا كانت واضحه وان لدى بلادي
ادله لا تقبل الشك على عدم وجود قنبله
قادره فيها
للطاقه الذريه واضحه وفضل الوكاله في زار
الاماكن التي ذكرها المسؤولون الروسي
ادعاءاتهم حول القنبله القذره المزعومه
اعطينا الوكاله كل الحريه للعمل داخل هذه
المنشات والان لدينا تاكيد بشكل قاطع ولا
يمكن الطعن فيه بعدم وجود القنبله القذره
في اوكرانيا الشيء الوحيد القدر
على الدوله الروسيه ويرحبون اوكرانيا
والعالم
واضاف زلزال روسيا لن تنجح في محاولتها
ابلال الشعب الاخراني من خلال استهدافها
منشاه الطاقه
المتضرره في عده مناطق تزود ملايين
الاشخاص بدايه من الليله قطعت الكهرباء عن
اربعه ملايين ونصف مليون مستهلك مؤقتا من
اجل تعليل خصوصا في كتاب وعشر مناطق اخرى
رجوع روسيا الى مهاجمه
وهي تسعى
للكسلته ولكنها لم تنجح في ذلك